after aun and his dragons burned our
last king Haron the black and broke our
armies the defeated iron born chose my
ancestor Reon Gro as lord of the iron
Islands not King the stories claimed
that the old way died would Hern the
black and his sons at her Hall our ships
and axes were no match for Egon dragons
so our ancestors bend their steel into
Fish Hooks and our kingdom into Villages
and started telling the R Tales around
the fire of how we used to be strong and
how one day we would be so again
Generations later a young boy listened
to them Dalton grey Joy the wild young
heir to Pik was rowing at five and
reaving a 10 in the Basilisk Isles with
his uncle by 14 Dalton had sailed as far
as old geese fought in a dozen battles
and claimed for soft wives for free you
can now listen to the entire Audi book
Fire and Blood On which house of the
Dragon is based and which covers the
entire targaryan history including
current and future events of House of
the Dragon for free with a notable trial
using our Link in the
description and his 15th year he Avenged
his uncle's death and battle but he took
a dozen wounds and emerged from the
fight drench head to heal in
blood from that day forth men called him
the red Kraken during the dance of
dragons the red Kraken picked the side
that was fighting the Lannisters and
fell upon the westerlands while the
Lannisters were of at War costly Rock
itself proved too strong once the lady
of the castle bed skates but the
ironborn burned the Lannister Fleet and
sacked lannisport carrying off gold
grain and hundreds of women and girls
including Lord Lannister's favorite
mistress and and all his bostard the red
Kraken now ruled the sunset sea as his
forbears had and his long ships again
brought the old way to the coast of wus
but then the war ended and the mainland
armies came home the Iron Throne
commanded the red Kraken to stop
breathing and when he didn't a mistress
opened his throat as he slept while his
son squabbled the Lannister send their
soldiers to the AR
Islands thousands of men women and
children were put to the sword and
scores of villages and hundreds of long
ships were put to the torch the Glorious
return to the old way had lasted almost
years it should not be hard to recruit
Lords into a war against an enemy known
as the Mad King we can even understand
the Lords who chose to honor their Oaths
and fight for him but the Krakens of
house GR Joy set out Robert's rebellion
and Pike with their tentacles up their
ass my father quellin was old and
sitting is what old people do best well
second best he would have set out the
whole War if not for my brother and me
we convinced him that nobody would fear
the walls of the sea if we curled up by
our fires While others feasted on The
Spoils of the Mad King so the old man
cred into his Rusty armor and set SA for
the reach only to be rowed by Terrell
longboats when my father sadly fell in
battle my older brother Balin beat a
tactical Retreat to his own inheritance
as the new Lord of the iron Islands I'd
rather die in The Reach than live on the
iron
Islands the roses are prettier to pluck
but my brother was getting old and felt
that longing to sit and the Sea Stone
chair was as good at place as any within
a few years he realized that sitting is
only fun if everyone else has to stand
he had the priest reforge no that's not
right they picked up sticks on the beach
W them into a new ancient Driftwood
crown and declared Balon the king of the
iron Islands unfortunately for my
brother the other king in wus Robert
barathan was famously bad as sharing and
his father by law and Warden of the West
Tywin Lannister had a mighty Fleet at
lannisport would un striking thiss of
the iron Islands yes you were very
clever and How brave burning our ships
at anchor in the
night they would have burned the same in
daylight I's a lazy Beast you didn't
Rouse until long after I set fire to a
proud main I planned it all you know my
first torch took your father's Flagship
if it makes you feel better we didn't
lud it out of
respect and
time I don't think I ever saw Robert
happier than the day he heard about the
grey Joy
Rebellion he'd been king for a handful
of years and many handfuls of other
things and it was clear to him and
everyone else how ill suited he was to
rule but battle he could do unfortun
fortunately by the time we raised our
army we seemed to be winning the war
balon's eldest son your nephew died
trying to storm seagard and his men were
thrown back into the arms of their
Drowned God if we wanted battle we'd
have to hurry North before the ironborn
put down their own rebellion and we
would have if I had my way rebelling was
a stupid idea never stopped your people
before before Balon put those sticks on
his head I told him that if he wanted to
rule the iron islands all he had to do
was give King Robert a tour of them why
waste our forces fighting a war we
couldn't win for a place our enemy
wouldn't want with the iron Fleet we
could Reef not just Wester us but the
rich Lands Beyond The Sunset sea but my
brother was too attached to that seaone
chair he commanded me to saell the iron
Fleet against Robert's Navy before we
could Ferry his army to Pike a Navy
commanded by Robert's younger brother
Stannis most known for sitting in a
besieged castle eating dogs and horses
remind me how did you fare against a man
who' never commanded ships in battle
nearly too well Stannis smashed your
iron Fleet at Fair Isle after I sailed
it into a straet where our numbers and
the size of our ships would work against
us it took some doing to convince my men
to rush into such an obvious trap
Stannis was not a subtle man you would
rather claim treason than defeat Victory
would have only delayed it we couldn't
hold off Robert's forces forever but we
could waste enough ironborn that we
wouldn't even fill our own Islands after
the war I made sure the silence escaped
that was enough for me that and watching
your army smash my brother's Castle soon
afterwards why didn't you just abandon
him after Fair a why risk your precious
life fighting for him at Pike I wanted
to kill the best knights in
Wester you failed so did you I expected
Pursuit when I fled p on the silence but
I suppose you were too busy not
punishing my brother to not punish the
man who burned your father's
Fleet where the north has its honor and
the South its chivalry the iron islands
has its strength we call ourselves the
ironborn and we are warriors feared
throughout the the Seven
Kingdoms or so we used to be unlike
their Mainland cousins the first men of
the iron Islands never bowed to the old
gods theirs was the Drowned God who made
the ironborn to Reeve and Sack and write
their names in salt steel and song that
his enemy the storm God could not wash
away we raised our Kings from our own
ranks and used beaten foes as THS to
work our minds and farm Our Land or
assault wives if a woman was pretty
enough such was the old way and while we
followed it we held sway wherever the
waves were
heard when aegon came demanding fty King
Haron the black ruled as far east as the
Trident other kings like the Starks
could kneel but Haron was ironborn and
the ironborn must be
beaten in Haron Hall he had the
mightiest Castle in Westeros and the
Army to defend it but aegon did not
intend a
Siege he mounted his dragon and roasted
Haron and all his sons in their Tower
and the oldway with them because of
haren's defiance Aon pushed the ironborn
back to our islands and gave the
riverlands to the tules but he did allow
the ironborn to choose who would lead
them house Greyjoy had always been one
of the greatest houses of the iron
Islands we Trace our descent from the
age of Heroes and the legendary gray
King who took a mermaid to wife and made
War upon the storm God for a thousand
years blessed by the Drowned God the
great king fought and slew Naga the
great sea dragon and took her fire for
his
own this history made our ancestor Vicon
Greyjoy the Natural Choice to lead the
ironborn after aon's
Conquest for 300 years house Greyjoy
ruled the ironborn we styled ourselves
lord of the iron Islands king of Sultan
Rock Son Of The Sea wind Lord Reaper of
Pike in truth we were
THS our people still chanted what is
dead may never
die but the old way had died until the
targaryens followed their dragons into
the grave and our Lord father Balon
Greyjoy Rose against the new King Robert
Baratheon Dark Wings dark
words I was only a when the Raven came
to call my father Lord edad Stark to
another
War Balon grey Joy had raised the iron
Islands in Revolt and burned the
Lannister Fleet at anchor King Robert
Baratheon again needed his old
friend my mother Catelyn was not happy
to lose her Lord husband to Robert again
six years before he had left her to
avenge his father and brother against
the Mad King but now he had Sons and
Daughters of his own and unspoken
another son who wasn't hers from the
last time he went to war my brother John
snow but she knew that in marrying my
father she had married the north we hold
our honor and Duty as dear as our old
gods when the time came my father
marched South to restore peace and order
to the
realm my father always told me the iron
Islands were a strange and dangerous
place its people the ironborn keep
neither the old gods nor the seven and
despise all honest toil their ancestors
ravaged the Western Shores and putting
it to the torch and their songs still
ring through the holes of the ironborn
while everywhere else they're whispered
to wayward children at bedtime perhaps
Lord Balon thought Westeros had not
healed from the war against the Mad King
and was as fragmented and suspicious as
the ancient kingdoms his forbears had
terrorized Robert's Navy corrected him
at Fair aisle when they smashed the iron
Fleet Robert and my father corrected him
at Pike his own castle when they pulled
down his towers and breached his
walls my father never liked to speak of
his battles but from other men I learned
what
transpired thoros of Mia was first
through the breach with his flaming
sword not far behind him was Jor moront
of bear Island my father's Bannerman who
earned the Knighthood he would lay to
shame and Lords from every corner of the
Seven Kingdoms
all day through every passage in the
castle they fought side by side my
father with our ancestral sword ice and
King Robert with his Warhammer against a
horde of Axe wielding
ironborn in the end Lord Balon bent the
knee King Robert generously allowed Lord
Balon to retain his title and
Castle the price of Peace was custom the
only son of balons to survive as foolish
Rebellion would be taken as a hostage
against future
treasons my father even volunteered to
Foster the boy himself I suspect to make
Theon grey Joy a different man than his
father who would bring honor and duty to
the iron Islands when he returned as
Heir so my mother's silent fear came
true and my father returned with another
child